yes it's the movie no one asked for and
who better to produce a covet-inspired
horror turd than the master of subtlety
himself
michael bay bumblebee stop lubricating
shot entirely during the pandemic
songbird tells the story of a mutated
covet virus called
kovid 23 with an insane mortality rate
of 56 percent so put on your masks or
preferably hazmat suits and make sure to
like and subscribe
because we're going to take a look at
this plague of a movie we
are 213 weeks into lockdown and i'm
currently in a city where we're on week
three of a lockdown and i'm already
going insane so
holy crap covet has completely decimated
the economy to the point where cities
look like something from
i am legend we meet our film's
protagonist nico who is one of a few
people
immune to the virus you might remember
this actor as playing hold on let me
check my notes here
nico in another movie or archie in the
best written show of all time
riverdale the general population calls
these immune people munis and looks down
upon them partially out of jealousy and
partially because even though they're
immune they can still spread the virus
so naturally niko's a delivery boy since
he can navigate the world freely without
fear of being
infected nico's tasked with sending a
package to the griffins an extremely
affluent family who will find out engage
in a legal sale of immunity wristbands
the hot ticket item among the extremely
rich are these wristbands which sell for
about 150k a pop
allowing those who wear it to travel
freely and out of their homes it also
means they won't be sent to the dreaded
q
zones or quarantine zones places where
people live in extreme conditions and
are sent to die
every day these citizens have to engage
in a virus check via their phones it's
never explained how this is done with
your phone but hey that's just the
beginning of the problems with this
movie so nico is saving up all his cash
to buy a contraband immunity bracelet
for his girlfriend sarah a girl he's
never
actually met he hands her a love note
through these uv
virus killing machines which is kind of
crazy they go through all this trouble
to keep their distance
the virus is airborne now apparently yet
there's a huge slit under the door
so we're about 20 minutes into the movie
and nothing has happened yet there's no
real story to talk about
so the writers probably knowing this are
like we need to bring out the big guns
and no i didn't mean a pun there
alexandra d'addario she plays some sort
of web streamer and forms a relationship
with dozer a
wheelchair-bound army vet who donates
hundreds of dollars to her
then we meet the film's villain emmett
harland who is the real highlight of the
movie
he works for the department of
sanitation which is in control of
rounding up the infected and sending
them to these q-camps he's here to pick
up an infected from sarah's apartment
but stumbles upon
this guy who is outpassed curfew and you
know what happens to those who are up
past
curfew you get stabbed
emmett here doesn't wear any protective
gear that's because he's immune
just like nico he ends up taking sarah's
infected neighbor alice away and here's
where the plot of the movie
actually begins it only takes about 40
minutes sarah's grandmother lita who she
lives with comes down with the virus
so nico vows to get an immunity pass for
sarah before the department of
sanitation comes to take her away
so the movie kind of becomes this race
against time will nico be able to get
the pass before
sarah is hauled away to the q zone nico
ends up going to the griffins because
he knows they've been dealing in those
super expensive immunity bands
and piper sets him up by giving the
number of emmett who's their inside guy
supplying them with these bands but what
nico doesn't know is that this is
actually a setup meanwhile mr griffin
jeopardizes the life of his immune
compromised daughter by cheating on his
wife and having romantic rendezvous with
d'addario i mean
i mean who wouldn't apparently he's
promised her a record deal or something
i mean i don't know how hollywood works
and the next morning
sarah and lita have to do their
mandatory virus check and of course lita
fails miserably but
sarah is miraculously fine nico meets
emmett in an abandoned building and i'm
like
couldn't they have met somewhere a
little nicer like an abandoned starbucks
not like anyone is out here so emmett
asks for sarah's information like where
she lives and stuff but he's really
wanting this so he can find it where she
is
and arrest her for the q zone but nico
picks up on this and oh no here we go
again with the stabbing nico manages to
get away with a minor flesh wound
just a flesh wound as heavily armed
guards with the department of sanitation
come after him
and just as nico is cornered and about
to be gunned down this random guy comes
out of nowhere and
saves him why are you even helping me
this is like the biggest deus ex machina
this guy's only purpose in the story is
to save nico and we're with him for
about 30 seconds and then he just
disappears what are you doing
i'm staying okay all right so may
confines in dozer that mr griffin has
been getting creepily obsessed with her
i mean look at these texts it's like me
trying to get back with my ex
stephanie please answer me so she calls
him and tells him it's over and if he
pursues her she'll leak recordings that
prove he has been dealing with those
fake immunity bands and i gotta give
this guy props his whole life could be
ruined and his response is
you're dumping me on the phone and idiot
guy is having this conversation with the
door open
and his wife overhears everything so
what do you do when someone's going to
destroy your entire life
grab your gun and take care of business
that is unless your wife gets in the way
she basically tells him to get out which
he does and she calls may to warn her
that william is on his way
mae then calls dozer fearing for her
safety and he sends out his drone to
watch after her it makes me wonder what
else has he been creeping on with that
drone nico breaks into the griffon home
now knowing that piper set him up and
demands she hand
over an immunity band and she does after
hearing about how in love he is
but just as he gets the band the
sanitation department arrives to pick up
sarah
and her now dead grandmother like how
slow are these guys
nico was able to go home then bike to
the griffins meet up with emmett
escape go back to the griffins all in
the time it took this sanitation team to
arrive
the government am i right so this team
of sanitation department people fully
clad in hazmat suits
bust into this tiny apartment and i kid
you not sarah is able to
knock one of these guys out and get into
his full hazmat
suit without alerting the others like
look how huge these things are and is no
one gonna be like hey
where's tom wasn't he supposed to help
with picking up this body it isn't until
a few minutes later that emmett finds
the hazmat dude's body just laying in
the middle of the room and realizes
sarah has escaped
meanwhile mae packs up her things to
head on over to dozers and you know
can't forget your guitar you you need
the essentials when of course her
car won't start william arrives and
harasses her
you think you're just gonna leave me and
dozer's drone is conveniently armed with
a gun
this is my favorite part though dozer
texts her after she's clearly terrified
with
i've always got your six so emmett
tracks down sarahware surprise
surprise we find out she's immune too
but she's broken the law and will be
sent
off to the q zone and in the very next
scene nico goes to sarah's apartment and
somehow emmett has magically teleported
there
i don't even know why he's come back and
this is the kind of scene in the movie
where the villain explains why he's so
twisted
telling nico that since they're both
immune they're basically gods
we're not human anymore
and he tries to stab him what is with
this guy he's stabbing like all his
co-workers have giant guns he
he couldn't get one either nico was able
to stab back with one of sarah's pencils
she's an artist and drew a picture of
him and finds sarah's phone which okay
try to follow along here because i was
so confused
she previously took a photo of the truck
the one that's going to be taking her
away
and put it as her phone's background
perhaps hoping that nico would see it
and be able to track her
the the amount of things that need to go
perfect here are mind-boggling so nico
is able to call lester to get dozer's
murder drone to track this truck and
stop it before reaching the q zone just
as she's been taking off the truck he
rushes to her and
slips on the immunity bracelet and no
one is like hey um
she didn't have one of those when we
picked her up maybe we should look into
that and these guys go from like ready
to blow up their brains mode to oh sorry
for the mix-up you're free to go now
here's a part i don't understand
nico and sarah embrace for the first
time and kiss but
nico doesn't know she's immune yet he
could be giving her the virus and i'm
like what was this whole movie about if
he's just gonna endanger her like that
but
she tells him it's okay
i'm like you that's where the movie
basically ends the two of them end up
venturing off to big sur where there's
probably nothing since the whole world
is a hellscape
nico gives lester an immunity bracelet
and there's some like d
storyline where the griffin's maid ends
up with her family which i
totally didn't get but hey why not i
think this movie's biggest crime isn't
that it exploits a pandemic
but provides us with nothing new
inventive or worth spending our time
the characters are flat the story
doesn't start until 40 minutes into the
movie and for a film about a pandemic we
see
only one person succumb to it so if you
want to submit yourself to some torture
check out songbird which i have no idea
why they called it songbird there's no
damn birds in it at all
thanks for watching make sure to like
and subscribe and check out my worst
movies and tv shows playlist with tons
of other videos
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram thinkstoryyt
and until next time remember daddy loves
you very much